the Joe Rogan experience I don't think
there's anything people do to live that
could be wrong I just think we could be
really smart and organize it better
likely create a whole new thing since we
have all these computers and
intelligence open to us and available to
us plus the thinkers that know how to
program those and you know programmers
and all those people that know about 0 &
1 & 1 you know mm-hmm
just [ __ ] invent something way better
that helps people and I know people have
the brains to do that in about an hour
if somebody I'll be that leader I mean
if that's called for somebody just has
to tell them to do it I think I think
people need to figure out a way to
profit off helping people that's where
things would get good
the problems are yes problem I know but
[ __ ] that that's all gonna go there's
not gonna be any more money we mean it's
all gone it's not like I just don't
think there's gonna be any more money
you know there was this Google quantum
computing [ __ ] yeah this Google quantum
computing thing they think it's a huge
threat to cryptocurrency yeah I don't
I'm too stupid to understand whether or
not they're right but I'm Way too
uninformed to but what they're trying to
say is that there's no way you would be
able to encode or encrypt this
information that would keep it from this
insane computing power that they're
developing yeah there is there is yeah
there's a way to get around all of it
and I I don't know why I'm like I mean I
know I'm on the autism spectrum spectrum
yeah
and you know a lot of us autistic people
we we just started talking to each other
on the internet quite a while ago about
like hey let's try to envision solutions
to everyday problems that actually
people face and and that threaten them
and see what we can come up with
and so there's whole websites about it
and I wish I had them but I I will post
them after I do the [ __ ] research so
I can't get a goddamn assistant to do
any goddamn research I can't you get a
sister
who's that journalist lady she was
asking about did you find her
tiffany tiffany who's it she had just
actually tweeted about Rosanna oh well
she's my friend oh okay that makes sense
I was like that is I know we've been
friends for a number of different live
she lives down there in the South in
well I don't know she wants me to say
well don't say south oh she might well
what did she write some good [ __ ] like
did you see her story on George Clooney
no I don't know anything about her so I
know that that billion dollar tequila he
was selling with Randy Gerber they got
they got it added up to being worth 1
billion dollars by that company that
owns the most liquor stores in the world
and roads and trucks and blah blah you
know their distribution channel is a
good one a billion dollars and uh and
the stuff they make tequila with well
y'all have to read the article it's for
people who fancied themselves
progressive and then when their eyes
beheld what the left actually does with
its invested money they're their eyes
bug out and what is he doing with this
tequila money well it's not what he did
you're doing with it it's how they
valued it it's like you just shows you
how corrupt everything is everything is
totally but if I can scale I'm confused
because it's just like a successful
tequila business writers are something
wrong with what the way they're doing it
in some way some people are saying you
know that the recipe it's grown in
families for generations right and it's
to there it's like a Walmart kind of
deal to their demise you know the the
products they used to produce the
tequila's so they're like getting
waylaid like in a Walmart shopping cart
called
George Clooney's company and these
families who have lived for generations
are getting the screwed end deals like
they do when Walmart
in the community okay I see what you're
saying so so people who are progressive
they need to know where all that
OneWorld e crap goes mmm I don't think
they know so what you're saying is that
he is basically profiting off of the
hard work of these people that are
remaining poor and they're buying their
formula and then using that formula to
make that tequila and they're growing
everything but they're making all the
profits that were saying yeah I think
it's about a Gavi which is a resource
right and I think it's about growing
that and the native people owning it
rather than it being bought out from
Andhra so yeah it's a whole one world
issue
[Applause]